buenos días continúan las protestas en
las afueras de la embajada de nilmar
aquí en el reino unido en el centro de
londres desde las afueras de la embajada
el diplomático le ha pedido al gobierno
británico no reconocerá lo passador
designado por la junta ha dicho que en
febrero de este año hubo un golpe
militar en su país y que éste se ha
trasladado ahora aquí al centro de
londres ha dicho además que el staff de
la embajada los trabajadores han sido
amenazados por la junta de graves
castigos si no cooperan el embajador
tuvo que pasar la noche en su carro
porque como ya lo anunciaban no se le ha
permitido el ingreso a la sede
diplomática este embajador ha estado en
la mira podría decirse del gobierno de
la junta militar de mianmar porque ha
exigido la liberación de todos los
retenidos especialmente de la ex líder
andy sans souci